well
if you've lost chuck todd
this sunday the struggling biden
presidency our new nbc news poll sinking
numbers for president buy none
competence handling a crisis and most
importantly the economy americans have
lost their confidence in president biden
and their optimism for the country a
shocking 71 percent say we're on the
wrong track and that includes a near
majority of democrats who are saying
that president biden's approval rating
stands at a dismal 42 percent
republicans believe it or not have
double-digit leads in dealing with
border security inflation
crime national security
the economy
and shockingly on getting things done
about the only good news for mr biden
and the democrats in this poll is that
the midterm elections aren't for another
year
well there's some nice halloween candy
for you
if you ask anyone in england to name a
famous comedy skit chances are they'll
say monty python's dead parrot
a guy buys a parrot in a pet store then
finds out it's dead he goes back to
complain but the owner insists the bird
is alive it's not dead it's resting he
protests as john cleese repeatedly bangs
the dead parrot on the counter then
drops it lifelessly to the floor
well this was the week it became clear
that the biden presidency is in fact
dead
it's not resting it's not in some
temporary slump
just like the parrot in that monty
python skate it is a presidency that is
no more that has ceased to be it has
expired and gone to meet its maker this
is an ex-presidency
on thursday they wheeled by now yet
again to trundle up to capitol hill and
beg his party to pass his infrastructure
build they refused all to be precise the
progressives refused the far left
refused
too many novos for the to pass today
in the words of that famous new york
daily news headline about president ford
refusing to bail out new york they told
biden drop dead
and that was the moment the biden
presidency died
the three central miserable dynamics of
this appalling man biden were all on
display first of all why did he delay
his trip to europe to beg for the
infrastructure bill on thursday there
was no actual deadline no real world
justification it was all about biden's
ego he wanted to show off to the other
politicians at the ludicrous climate
summit in glasgow he didn't want to be
embarrassed humiliated but in the end he
was humiliated by his own party and it
was all totally unnecessary driven not
by the national interest but biden's
personal vanity
it was exactly the same with afghanistan
he insisted on a reckless deadline just
so he could make some sick speech on the
anniversary of 9 11. the cost of that
wasn't just humiliation but the lives of
hundreds of afghans and 13 american
soldiers
biden could have passed his
infrastructure bill by now if it wasn't
for his vanity but no his head was
turned by a bunch of historians telling
him he could be the new fdr the new
lyndon johnson passed sweeping
legislation but fdr won with 57 of the
popular vote his party had a majority of
23 in the senate and
196 in the house
lyndon johnson won with 61
a majority of 36 in the senate and 155
in the house what's biden even thinking
put him himself in that category there
was no biden landslide he barely got a
majority of the popular vote 51
democrats have eight more seats in-house
no majority at all in the senate
yet biden went along with a plan to link
the two bills in one giant scheme to
centralize power in the federal
government and bureaucracy
all because of his vanity
biden's a complete narcissist all he's
ever wanted is to be president the
problem is hardly anybody else agreed
that's the second dynamic that was on
display last week biden has zero
authority in the primaries fourth in
iowa fifth in new hampshire biden only
survived because of jim clyburn in south
carolina biden didn't persuade anyone he
didn't inspire anyone he just had to be
not bernie sanders who the democratic
establishment was desperate to stop so
they all fell in line even though they
knew how decrepit biden was and then in
the general election biden didn't make
an argument he hid in the basement no
vision just a vacuum i'm not bernie and
i'm not trump can anyone remember a
single substantive thing biden said
we've never seen such an empty
presidential campaign the entire thing
was a big bunch of nothing from a small
shriveled non-entity he entered the oval
office with zero authority and now he
has even less as everyone can see how
fully he's failing and how fast he's
fading physically and mentally
and and
what am i doing here
good question
which brings us to the third and
defining biden dynamic he is a machine
politician who believes in nothing but
advancing his own career that's why
there was no leadership that's why his
little trip to capitol hill made
absolutely no difference he may hang on
for another three years
but as this week showed he is totally
irrelevant to anything that's actually
happening now he's a joke the world over
we're used to this in sports arenas in
america
[Applause]
or a protest against vaccine mandates
[Applause]
but now
it's video game streamers it's airline
pilots
it's made its way to halloween
decorations auntie
even spreading around the world this was
in rome
but last week was no ordinary political
disaster yes they'll no doubt end up
passing their two bills maybe even later
this week but does anyone think that
will make things better it won't work in
political terms because after all the
public haggling it will be seen as a
defeat for everyone
and it won't work in policy terms
because it's such bad policy
who thinks spending more money is a
smart move when inflation is spiraling
out of control not even obama's chief
economic advisor jason furman he told
the new york times this week that
biden's first giant spending bill was
too much let alone another one quote
the original sin was an oversized
american rescue plan it contributed to
both higher output but also higher
prices
who thinks increasing welfare payments
is a good idea when the main reason we
have a supply chain crisis with empty
shells in the stores is that businesses
can't find workers because biden was
paying them to stay home
how can biden and his gang of
incompetence fix the multiple cascading
disasters america faces when they were
the ones who caused them you can't fix
the immigration crisis if you tell
people you want a surge at the border if
you tell ice not to enforce the law if
you pay people nearly half a million
dollars for coming here illegally if you
do that they come in ever greater
numbers
is biden going to turn around and say oh
actually we're not for open borders now
he can't it's the core ideology of his
party
this feeble old fool couldn't challenge
it even if he wanted to
you can't fix the energy crisis if you
spend all your time virtue signaling at
global summits while cutting domestic
energy production you can't fix the
afghanistan crisis if you ignore the
advice from your top generals pull
everyone out and hand the country over
to the exact same terrorist monsters who
harbored bin laden
and so here we are
a president in office but not in power a
presidency that is no more that has
ceased to be it has expired and gone to
meet its maker this
is an ex-presidency
do you agree tell us what you think at
steve hilton x and at next year of fnc
and share this message when we post it